la veille la nuit a viré au cauchemar à
Taïwan un quartier connu pour son
atmosphère cosmopolite sébare et ses
lieux de fête en tout genre des milliers
de jeunes réunis pour célébrer la fête
de l'Halloween pour la première fois
depuis le début de la pandémie
deviennent vite prisonniers des petites
rues étroites du quartier
c'est le chaos la panique certains
tentes de fuir partout les moyens la
bousculade s'en suit des corps se
retrouve inanimés au sol après avoir vu
les gens qui s'acharnaient sur les
massages cardiaques puis les ambulances
qui arrivaient pas à sortir
j'avais du mal à possesser que ces gens
là pourraient s'en sortir
j'ai perdu mes amis pleure ce témoin
j'ai fait signe aux gens de ne pas venir
vers nous car je comprenais déjà ce qui
était en train de se passer les gens
mouraient
et cette tragédie résonne à travers le
monde du Vatican le pape François a
adressé ses condoléances aux familles
des victimes je pense aux personnes
touchées par cette tragédies et je
souhaite un bon rétablissement à celles
qui ont été blessées écrit le premier
ministre Justin Trudeau le président
français Emmanuel Macron et son
homologue américain Joe Biden ont aussi
adressé leurs condoléances au peuple
sud-coréen à la suite de cette nuit
d'horreur qui restera longtemps gravé
dans les esprits ici Daniel Kadjo
Radio-Canada Montréal